how is your lovely daughter Alice doing
how is she alice is great she is nine
years old now and she that's a great age
some age it's it's just again having a
being getting to be a dad getting to
raise a child is so awesome even with
there are there are costs to it there
are sacrifices there are things that you
okay this is this was the latest big hit
that I had to take I got invited to the
premiere of Han Solo the Han Solo
premiere
not only did I get invited but I got one
of those like VIP things right and the
night of the premiere and you were a man
you were one of the biggest fans like my
god yes I could add oh my god oh so hang
on so the night of the premiere was also
the night of my daughter's art fair at
her school her second grade art fair so
I had to go I had to go to her Art Fair
I couldn't go to the premiere and as if
to add insult to injury and then sure
she didn't mean to do this her art
project was the crappiest robot I've
ever seen
I'm sorry you didn't look don't you
didn't see it okay it looks like it
looked like a silver scrotum with a
robot head on it and I swear to God the
face on the robot had this look like
yeah I suck don't I
that's right yeah you want to be it
you're a five minute and by the way at
the Han Solo premiere not only did you
get to go to the premiere on Hollywood
Boulevard they had parked the Millennium
Falcon you could walk around in it take
pictures in it sit in the cockpit but I
had to stand in front of scrotum the
robot
and put on an Academy level acting
performance okay this is some Oh sweetie
oh my god is he gonna get up and move
around this is amazing and in my head
it's like the Millennium Falcon is two
minutes from me and I can't and I know I
know if you'd gone back to the summer of
77 when I was eight years old when I
just come out of Star Wars and you said
Patton that movie you just saw when
you're older you're gonna get invited to
a movie just about Han Solo and you're
gonna get to walk around the Millennium
Falcon and you won't be able to go
because it's gonna be your daughter's
art fair and you got to go to that
instead I know I know for a fact I would
have said I get to ladies
[Applause]
you